[Música]
Buenos días y bienvenidos a la
entrevista de Franz 24 nuestro invitado
de hoy es Rafael grossi director general
del organismo internacional de energía
atómica está con nosotros desde Viena
Muchas gracias Señor grossi gracias Es
un placer estar con ustedes hoy
Señor las armas nucleares rusas se
encuentran en peligro debido a los
acontecimientos de la semana pasada en
Rusia sabemos que una columna
paramilitar de Wagner pasó por la ciudad
de borones donde se encuentra una de las
12 principales bases de almacenamiento
de armas nucleares
sintió miedo y más en general se siente
tranquilo respecto a la seguridad de las
instalaciones y la cadena de Mando
nuclear rusa
dos cosas muy importantes y que quizás
estén relacionadas pero no directamente
preocupación
mi primera preocupación desde el
comienzo de la guerra ha sido la
protección de la central de saporilla
la situación
no ha mejorado evidentemente con la
contraofensiva y el aumento de la
actividad militar en el frente
los peligros que amenazan a la central
son cada vez mayores
estuve allá hace poco y
desafortunadamente también hay que
añadir los desastres la destrucción de
La Represa de novaka
y alteré el equilibrio de la función
que ha alterado Por así decirlo el
equilibrio de la función de enfriamiento
dada la Clara reducción de los niveles
de agua del río
que pasa cerca de la central y del que
se sacaba agua para enfriar los
reactores
así que todo esto diría yo está
confluyendo en una desafortunada
convergencia de acontecimientos que está
debilitando la situación de la central
la situación nuestros equipos siguen
estando allá y estamos observando la
evolución de la situación el resto sigue
más o menos la lógica del conflicto
y el Hoya no tiene mucho que decir al
respecto
voy a volver al tema de la central de
esa polilla porque el 22 de junio Hace
unos días el presidente ucraniano
que según sus servicios de inteligencia
Rusia había hecho todos los preparativos
para atacar la central su jefe de
inteligencia militar fue aún más allá y
declaró esta semana que las tropas rusas
habían desplazado vehículos cargados de
explosivos alrededor de cuatro de los
seis reactores de la central y que el
estanque de enfriamiento de la central
había sido minado por las tropas rusas
usted tiene un equipo en el terreno es
cierta esta información
tiene pruebas de que estos preparativos
realmente fueron llevados a Cabo
nuestros equipos están allá y aunque no
conozco el informe que acaba de
mencionar puedo decirle que no hay un
despliegue militar de tal escala
nuestros equipos no lo ven
dando lo hemos dicho en nuestras
actualizaciones en nuestros informes
casi diarios sobre la situación en la
central
hemos tenido información sobre
operaciones de minado en el perímetro
exterior de la central
lo que obviamente va en contra las
medidas normales de seguridad y de la
seguridad nuclear en tiempos de paz
Así que lo hemos reportado pero tengo
que decir que y repito
no conozco exactamente los documentos
que usted menciona
pero puedo decir que no hay ningún
despliegue importante en el interior de
la central
o en el recinto de la central que podría
confirmar esta información
dicho esto estamos muy alerta
especialmente desde mi presentación ante
el consejo de seguridad de las Naciones
Unidas hace unas semanas
Y aquel que se ven donde expuse los
principios básicos que deben respetarse
y las cosas que deben evitarse para
prevenir un accidente nuclear
me pasaban accidente
y obviamente la instalación de
explosivos y el minado de los sistemas
de la central van en contra de eso
pero no es lo que hemos visto al menos
por ahora
entonces las advertencias ucranianas
incluidas las del presidente sobre un
posible nuevo chernóbil esta vez causado
por un ataque por ahora ustedes no lo
constatan sobre el terreno
por ahora pero me mantengo cauteloso
porque como usted lo dijo se habla de
planes se habla de proyectos etcétera y
no somos una agencia de inteligencia
verdad
Así que no sé a qué nivel de información
se refieren y no puedo especular no me
puedo dar el lujo de especular al
respecto
Pero lo que sí puedo decir es que
estamos alerta nuestros inspectores
nuestros expertos están allá y
obviamente Si vemos algo que apunte En
esa dirección lo informaremos de
inmediato
lo que usted intentó hacer y no funcionó
fue establecer una zona desmilitarizada
alrededor de esta central
está ocupada por los rusos y hay
combates como usted dice cada vez más
cerca
de ahora en adelante es impensable tener
una zona desmilitarizada
no no diría que es impensable Es decir
tenemos que adaptar nuestros enfoques y
nuestras propuestas a las realidades
puede que yo haya deseado Puede que haya
pensado que eso era lo ideal
habíamos comenzado y creo que cuando
usted habíamos hablado sobre este tema
en un proceso de negociación con Rusia y
Ucrania la posibilidad de establecer una
zona de protección
obviamente en el momento en el que
aumentan las actividades militares
cuando se empieza a hablar de
contraofensiva ningún jefe militar
aceptará decir que hay perímetros
territoriales a los que no tienen acceso
por eso cambiamos el enfoque ya hablamos
más bien de acciones que deben evitarse
atacar la central militarizar la central
etcétera
y es respecto a este tema creo que he
recibido bastante apoyo incluso de Rusia
y Ucrania
la situación es muy frágil estamos
hablando de una guerra y de combates
activos en este momento así que tenemos
que permanecer vigilantes las 24 horas
del día y ver cómo evolucionan las cosas
voy a mencionar brevemente el tema de
Irán según su último informe las
reservas de uranio enriquecido de Irán
han aumentado más de una cuarta parte en
tres meses y sin embargo hace tres meses
en marzo ustedes el oia e Irán habían
acordado nuevas medidas de verificación
y control Pero obviamente esto no está
funcionando
Funciona muy lentamente
y yo mismo he dicho en mis
conversaciones y consultas con mis
colegas iraníes que esperamos mucho más
después de este acuerdo al que llegamos
el 4 de marzo en Teherán
al final del cual acordé con las
autoridades iraníes
me reuní con el presidente de la
república y otros altos funcionarios el
ministro de asuntos exteriores etcétera
acordamos que primero trabajaríamos
juntos para aclarar las cosas que Irán
necesita aclarar Y que debe proporcionar
información sobre los lugares de Irán en
los que el organismo ha encontrado
restos de uranio
y No deberíamos porque haber visto ni
encontrado restos de uranio
y luego acordamos que Irán aceptaría
medidas adicionales de verificación y
monitoreo
adicional de verificación de bonito
hogar y en este sentido hemos avanzado
muy parcialmente
muy yo diría limitadamente
eso es lo que estamos discutiendo
actualmente y creo que continuaremos
este proceso durante el verano
mientras esto ocurre como usted bien
dice las reservas de uranio enriquecido
al 60 25% aumentan y siguen aumentando
como que de plugin así que se han
cruzado varias líneas que antes se
consideraban zonas que no se debían
traspasar
pero se ha traspasado y también vemos
que las negociaciones entre los países
del llamado plan de acción integral
conjunto se Han detenido
se habla de otros procesos de
negociación de acuerdos bilaterales
etcétera
cree en eso
creo que cualquier acuerdo es mejor que
no tener ningún acuerdo
para intentar dar una confianza que no
existe es positiva
Creo que lo único que debemos tener
claro en esta discusión Es sobre qué se
está discutiendo la discusión
para nosotros en el organismo es
absolutamente vital tener Claridad
sería un proceso paralelo Qué es en qué
consiste
Y qué podemos hacer como inspección
internacional para ayudar a demostrar
que estos acuerdos No solo son un papel
y que hay algo real detrás de ellos
Rafael García Rafael grossi Muchas
gracias por responder a las preguntas de
France 24 desde la sede de su agencia en
Viena
y gracias por seguir esta entrevista en
nuestro canal
[Música]